thanks everybody for being here this
morning Nick said Anthony randazza and a
lot of what I do is spend my time
looking at all the the wonderful housing
data that comes out every couple weeks
various metrics and talk with people on
the hill or people in the media about
really what all these numbers mean and
every every month somebody likes to say
well is is this the bottom of the
housing bubble or you know it's just
more where we're going to expect more of
this dissipation where is it going to go
and you can never tell from one
particular month but what we can tell is
we can look back to the past three years
of bush and then Obama's policies on
trying to fix the housing market and we
can look at three years of transit we
can see that that's not working and we
can look at the history of Fannie Mae
and Freddie Mac and we can see that
those guys in their system has it worked
but nothing has changed even looking at
that particular information and so there
seems to be a large opportunity for
change when it comes to housing finance
issues Fannie Mae Freddie Mac and
whatnot but nothing has really changed
so what I want to talk about this
morning is sort of from my perspective
why I see that's the case and maybe
wanted some of the things we might be
able to do to kind of push that forward
a few months ago I was talking with some
staff from a congressman from florida
republican congressman from florida and
this staffer had heard one of my tests
ified before the House Financial
Services Committee on how we can get rid
of Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac the big
mortgage giants and she was concerned
and the congressman was concerned that
my ideas which were being by Jesus other
people who are pushing for the getting
rid of frigging Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac those ideas are being adopted by
some Republicans she was concerned about
how this is going to impact housing
prices and particularly she said that
the congressman is concerned about how
this is going to hurt homeowners and we
don't want to get rid of she was very
clear no we we support free market ideas
we're very free market but we don't want
to get rid of a government program if
that's going to hurt taxpayers and
frankly as long as we have free markets
opponents like that the progressives can
just sit on the side
because we don't need to do much that's
that's not very free market at all the
problem was is that she and the
congressman who she worked for they
suffer from a conflict of values they
this comp particular congressman he's
filed against Obamacare II fought
against dodd-frank he very Republican in
those sense but when it comes to housing
issues there's a series of common wisdom
it may be one way of looking at it that
is sort of seeped into the mind of the
American psyche that is really confused
away a lot that people look at housing
some of these ideas are that housing is
a good investment that you probably have
heard it said to you throughout your
life that one of the best investments
when the best things you can do with
your resources is to become a homeowner
is to buy a home that's actually not
true another thing is that rising
housing prices are a good thing seems
like a relatively common piece of just
yeah sure housing prices going up it's a
good thing that's also not true even
this concept of an ownership society
that republican president george w bush
put forward seemed to push this idea
that public policy should go towards
promoting homeownership an ownership
society is somehow inherently a good
thing these ideas have clouded the the
minds of not just people on the left but
also people on the right when it comes
to trying to solve some of these housing
finance problems and i want to show you
some numbers on those particular things
the reality is that housing prices in
and of themselves going up that's not a
good thing it would traditionally we
think that the quality of something
going up and the price something going
down is a sign of good innovation
whether it's computing whether it's a
thinner better ipad that has more power
and a lower price over time we almost
everything we see quality going up and a
price going down as a good thing except
when it comes to housing for some reason
and the reason for that is this because
people see housing as a good investment
or if people want to they don't want
their gas prices to go up
because most people don't own gas as an
investment asset they want their gas
prices to go down but because they see
housing as an investment they want that
price to go up and another component in
this is the concept that renting is
somehow throwing money away this may be
a piece of common wisdom that you
yourself might hold and it's it's not
completely unheard of to think that you
know renting that rental check that you
give to your landlord every money or
every month is just going down a black
hole and what you should do to be a
fiscally responsible American is to own
a home so that your mortgage payments
are actually helping you to build equity
but I also want to show you some numbers
on this in a second you can actually if
you manage your your finances properly
being a renter can be just as fiscally
responsible if not more so than being a
homeowner so we have this we have this
opportunity with the scandal that is
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and several
years of failed homeownership or failed
policies church trying to fix the
housing market but we aren't moving
anywhere because we have these these
pieces of common wisdom that are sort of
infiltrating both American psyche and
members of Congress and it's pushed
people into four different camps that's
what I want to walk through is to try I
adeeb my thought is that the more we can
identify why people don't want to push
away from the status quo the more we can
identify not just here's the solutions
not just here's the free market solution
to the problem but we can identify why
people push back against that the the
easier it's going to be or potentially
easier it's going to be to try and push
past them these obstacles so we actually
do have an opportunity for change so the
first group is what I've just been
talking about and that is those who want
to see housing prices grow this right
here is housing prices from 1946 right
at the end of World War two through 2010
and pretty simple prices go up that drop
back down that's the housing bubble this
right here is widening the housing
bubble everybody said housing prices are
never going to go down don't worry
there's no such thing as a bubble
historically prices they have ever gone
down
this is why people advocate for housing
as an investment it's a good idea if
prices are always going to go up so
obviously you're building wealth but if
you adjust these numbers for inflation
that exact same data looks like this and
that is if you basically a starting peg
of 100 in the way that the index works
is that more or less prices don't jump
that much further away from inflation
but you can also see the housing bubble
here at the end and that is right around
the mid 90s all of a sudden we broke
away from this historical trend in
housing prices being attached inflation
and this is because this is when
affordable housing goals started this is
when the Jim Johnson Fannie Mae a
political machine began to take off and
really being a serious rent seeker and
regulatory capture or in Washington and
this is when really the housing
subsidies from the United States
government began to ramp up and it
pushes up this asset bubble now those
prices have begun to collapse and really
what we need is for those prices to get
back down to that historical trend line
of sticking with inflation however
people don't want this yeah if you
bought a home in 2005 or 2006 you
probably don't want these prices to come
back down either you you are under water
in your home you want prices to get back
up but if we want a recovery we need
that that to be all the way down at the
bottom so talking to people about this
in housing prices this is this is an
important piece of trying to get over
some of the hurdles to the the potential
opportunity for change so the second
camp of people that is out there those
that are pushing for this ownership
society that I talked about and these
are people that they see a correlation
between homeownership and social
socially good things less crime better
education people investing in their
community and so they argue that because
there's a correlation between social
benefits and homeownership that we
should push that however they're mixing
cause and correlation just because
someone is a homeowner doesn't
necessarily
Meenore take someone that's a renter and
you make them a hoe nor it doesn't
necessarily mean that you get all those
social benefits there's a lot of studies
that go into that but another part of
that is what I mentioned before renting
I'll walk you through very quickly and
we can talk about this in question and
answer later a brief experiment that we
ran if you bought a home in 1980 and you
and you had it as a median home you got
an eight point five percent 30-year
fixed-rate mortgage the median a
fixed-rate mortgage in nineteen eighty
and you paid it off over 30 years you'd
have a home worth two hundred and five
thousand dollars however if you invested
the difference between renting which the
difference between renting and a
mortgage payment was pretty significant
in the 80s it's narrowed since then so
it's actually not that much now but if
you invest the difference between
renting which is cheaper and owning a
home every month and you put it into the
SP at the end of 30 years you'd have
190,000 if you put it into a relatively
safe corporate bond index you'd have
almost four hundred thousand dollars at
the end of 30 years you could buy that
home that the person has been paying a
fixed rate mortgage off out right now
this isn't to say that renting is better
than home owning there you may favor
home owning because you want to have
more independence and you want to paint
your walls pink and fuchsia and your
landlord doesn't want you to do that or
you may want to rent because you have
more flexibility what this says is that
public policy shouldn't favor renting
over home owning and hopefully this is
some data that can begin to you know
something that we that are much more
free markets minded in this particular
crowd may intuitively sort of grasp this
is hopefully some information that can
push back on that false common wisdom so
the last two groups that i'll touch on
Ralph real quickly before I wrap up so
there's groups of people that think that
government subsidies stabilize the
housing market as unintuitive that may
seem given the instability of the
housing market now the idea is is that
if we have a government subsidy
investors will stay in the marketplace
even when they lose money because
they'll stay investing because they know
that Uncle Sam has the back and the idea
is is that we can some people say well
we just need to set a government
guarantee
on catastrophic losses sure well how the
private sector takes some losses if we
have a similar housing bubble burst like
this and the private sector will take
initial losses when it comes to
mortgage-backed securities and defaulted
mortgage backed securities but if the
boss is a really bad Uncle Sam will step
in even that situation even where
there's some incentives for investors to
pay attention to what they're looking at
winds up being sort of a self-fulfilling
crisis because ultimately that still
does distorts economic decision-making
for investors and you you wind up
destabilized in the housing market just
over a longer period of time so maybe if
we have government guarantees full out
will have 10 minutes 2 minutes left
we'll have well had 10 years of will
have 10 years of this a housing bubble
growing and then bursting kind of like
we have right now if we have a
catastrophic risk government guarantee
maybe it'll take 30 years eventually the
market does get destabilized and then
the final fourth camp are those who
think that government guarantees are
necessary for investors to even come to
the marketplace and I've talked to
people in the financial industry who
told me themselves look I'm not
investing in mortgages unless the
government is backing me up it's just I
want my government guarantee that's the
way the system has been built but if
there's a fine thing that happens when
you get rid of a government guarantee on
say a mortgage-backed security and that
is there's a higher yield if the
government is guaranteeing your your MBS
then that means there's low risk and
maybe you'll make a three percent profit
but if you have the exact same mortgages
in that mortgage-backed security and you
don't have a government guarantee that
yield on it could be something more like
seven percent which is highly attracted
to a lot of institutional investors and
so while there the perp people in the
marketplace who are used to a government
guarantee may want to stick with that
there are trillions of dollars of
institutional investors who are out
there that are investing in assets that
are just as risky as a mortgage-backed
security without a government guarantee
trillions
because they want that kind of a yield
so there's money available there how
much we don't really know particular
t'market has to set but when we can
convince [ __ ] like policymakers that
really there are people that invest in
this stuff all the time it's not always
mortgages but it's something else and we
can bring that data the idea is
hopefully that that fact can sort of
push past some of the roadblocks and
create an opportunity for change now and
allow us to input put in place a free
market solution now I have a lot of
ideas on what that free market solution
can be we don't have time to talk about
them in 30 seconds I can flip through
the seven things that I wanted to talk
about right here and leave that up for a
split second we can talk about this in
question and answer the the thing I
would leave you with is probably nothing
new you know the idea is hopefully if
you can present facts to policymakers
that will push past them but the day
that fax start winning in Washington is
the day that I no longer have to do my
job so it's definitely an uphill road of
putting these facts in place putting
these facts in front of policymakers
doesn't necessarily mean that will win
but there is a big opportunity for
change here and hopefully we can
continue to bring reason to this debate
and see what happens over the next
couple years thank you very much well
I'm afraid I'm going to have to run
through a kind of complicated issue
pretty quickly as well so I apologize in
advance if there are some of the nuts
and bolts of the pension issue that I
don't explain in depth but please feel
free to ask me in the question and
answer period if there's anything that I
don't cover when I first started writing
about pension issues back in 2004-2005 i
co-authored a study that reason
published called the gathering pension
storm how government pensions are
breaking the bank and strategies for
reform and there really was no media
coverage or interest in pension issues
at all and and the study didn't get
garner much interest either when I did a
follow-up study last year for California
alda how white California's or how
California's public pension system
gokhan and how to fix it by then people
were starting to get it and so it's
encouraging that at least we've started
to acknowledge the problem in all levels
of government really state local and
it's become a huge issue it is a very
nebulous one so I will try to get
through some of the main points here but
first I wanted to talk about salaries of
government employees as well since
that's one of the components of pensions
one of the one of the main driving
factors in pension increases is simply
hiring more government employees and
giving them higher salaries since that
affects the pension calculation now
here's a comparison from the bureau of
labor statistics comparing private
industry and state and local government
salaries and as you can see government
employees can have wages and salaries
about thirty four percent greater than
the private sector counter counterparts
and benefits about seventy percent
greater now as the labor unions will
point out and rightly so this is an
aggregate average and there are some
some factors like for example in the
private sector you tend to have more
retail and manufacturing positions that
are lower skill low wage and so those
will skew the numbers down a little bit
and and here's a similar similar
representation for federal government
employees and as you this is adding in
both the wages and the benefits and you
see that the federal employees are about
twice as much as the private sector
counterparts but to get more of an
apples-to-apples comparison USA Today
did an analysis last year looking at
just occupations that were common to
both the government sector and the
private sector and there were over 200
of these all together and you can see
their conclusions accountants nurses
chemists surveyors cooks clerks and
janitors are among the wide range of
jobs that get paid more on average in
the federal government than in the
private sector the federal pay premium
cut across all job categories white
collar blue collar
management professional technical and
low skill in all 180 jobs paid better
average salaries in the federal
government 36 paid better and private
sector so even when we have these common
occupations we see it in five out of six
cases that government employees are
working or earnings significantly more
on average and I hear the numerical
representations for for those
comparisons and if you look at the
number of government employees earning
the very highest salaries you can see
just in the last few years the the
number of federal employees earning
150,000 is 11 x greater than it was in
2005 and the number earning 180,000 or
more is about 20 times greater now to to
get more into the pension issue I wanted
to just kind of highlight some of the
demographics that are affecting this as
well I don't know how well you can see
the chart there but looking back to the
the turn of the 20th century only about
there were about two thirds of the
population of men aged 65 that were
you're still in the labor force at that
time you look at the end of the century
there that that figures dropped all the
way to twenty percent and you look at
the life expectancy race you see that
people are living significantly longer
so you have fewer people working after
65 and living longer that leads to the
typical person actually spending twice
as much in retirement as you did just a
couple generations ago and now on top of
this we have the baby boomer generation
starting to retire which is going to add
to the problem even more so how bad is
the pension situation well there are a
wide variety of estimates the Pew Center
on the state's estimated it at about one
trillion dollars although even that was
even they admitted that was low because
they were relying on mid-2008 data
before the the market collapsed there
and the Pew Center data rely just on the
numbers that the governments were
reporting and
as we can get into later those those
estimates tend to be low balled quite a
bit and some of the other estimates have
used different actuarial assumptions and
come out with two trillion three and a
half tree and maybe as much as five
trillion but the the problem is that
it's really hard to pin down any kind of
number since in a defined benefit system
the actuarial numbers are dependent upon
the assumptions that you make it depends
on how much you assume that the pension
fund is going to earn on average how
much you assume that the employees
salaries are going to go up and how much
inflation is going to go up when people
are going to retire and all these other
factors and then you have to try to
project these things out decades into
the future and here's a quote that I
like about the actuarial assumptions
from a former SEC attorney my experience
every pension fund I've ever seen has an
actuarial assumption that is more akin
to wishful thinking and what is
reasonably feasible so I wanted to talk
a little bit about what's being done
about pension problems and here's just
kind of a summary of what the states
have been doing most of the most of the
reforms to date have been involved
making employees pay more into their
pension systems adjusting the retirement
age and the eligibility and you can see
there are some that have tried to tackle
it through automate getting rid of some
automatic cost-of-living adjustments and
so forth there are just a handful of
states that have actually decided to
abandon the traditional defined-benefit
model and go to a 401k style defined
contribution model and the the most
recent of these is Utah and you can see
some of the the pension losses or some
of the losses of the pension fund that
have kind of led to the desperation that
they needed I guess to try to get some
of these reforms passed in Utah there
was a state senator by the name of
linquist who was a champion for pension
reform and Utah actually has a
legislature that was sympathetic to that
and so they were able to put in this
defined pension system where the state
contributes ten percent of the employees
salaries and they kick in a little more
for the public safety employees there is
still an option for employees to go with
a DB system but even in that case the
state's contribution is cap still at ten
percent now in in my home state of
California even where we have some of
the worst pension problems there have
been several academic studies that have
pegged the unfunded liabilities anywhere
in the 400 to 500 billion dollar range
which I know it is hard to even wrap
your mind around but it works out to
roughly thirty six thousand dollars for
every household in the state but even in
California there have been some signs in
in the waning days of the Schwarzenegger
administration and one good thing that
he did was to rollback pension levels to
what they were in 1999 for it applied
only to new employees but the the 1999
reform is called sb400 it actually
increased the pension benefits as much
as fifty percent for public safety
employees and in addition it made all of
those benefit increases retroactive
needless to say it was a it's been a
huge cost of the state at the local
level there there's been even greater
signs that there is an appetite for
reform in just the last election cycle
in November 2010 seven out of eight
cities passed their pension reform
measures and those tended to be things
concerning increasing contributions from
employees sometimes decreasing
contributions from the government or the
taxpayers and in a few cases they impose
the requirement saying that the voters
have to approve any future pension
increases I included some poll numbers
here just to indicate that there's there
is actually a great deal of grassroots
support for pension reform even go in
all the way to switch into a defined
contribution model
there really isn't any appetite at all
in Sacramento and so I wanted to
contrast this with Utah where you have
kind of a top-down approach to reforming
the pension system with California where
you have kind of more of a grassroots
effort and I think in California any
efforts if they're going to be
successful they're going to have to be
probably from the public on a ballot
measure but I think we will see that at
some point okay there there are a couple
other states as I have mentioned that
have gone to these defined contribution
plans Michigan switched all the way back
in nineteen ninety seven and a little
more recently Alaska switch to DC plans
in 2005 there are a number of states
that additionally have either a hybrid
plan where you have some sort of minimal
defined benefit plus a defined
contribution on top of that or an
optional defined contribution plan and
here's summary of those now as for the
solutions first thing is to stop the
bleeding of we've been digging a hole
for a long time and it's time to stop
digging that and I think the only way to
really solve that problem is to close
defined benefit plans and switch to the
defined contribution bottles and make
those those benefits more can to what we
see in private sector now some of some
of the states and local governments have
said well maybe if we can just increase
the retirement ages a little bit maybe
if we can shrink the defined benefit
pension formulas a little bit that'll be
enough to get us through I really don't
think that that's going to be the answer
in California they tried that back in
1991 they went to a so-called second
tier of lower benefits for all new hires
and then within a decade they had
increased benefits fifty percent not
only for the current or the new
employees but also as I mentioned they
made that retroactive and so I think
there's there's just too much temptation
and in statehouses to continue to
increase that defined benefit portion
even if you were to go to a hybrid plant
or something so I think you really need
to change the incentives and go
completely to a defined contribution
system the the board controversial
aspect that's just begun to be talked
about is whether you can reduce benefits
for current employees for future work
that they do in other words everything
up to this point would be locked in but
any future benefits that they haven't
earned yet might be able to be reduced
and it's really kind of a gray area
legally the little Hoover Commission in
California which is a bipartisan
oversight Commission has said there's
really no way that California is going
to be able to get out of it without
doing that and so I think more states
are going to have to start looking at
that as I mentioned the retroactive
benefit increases or a killer voter
approval requirements are another way to
act allow the voters to act as a final
check if there's some sort of collusion
between politicians and labor interests
as they're off it is then the voters at
least have a final say on whether some
plan benefit increases are really just
out of it completely out of whack or
they can't afford it and of course
switching to the defined contribution
plans I should point out that this is
not a cure-all solution you could make
benefits just as just as outrageous if
you if you set your your employer
contribution at a really high level so
you have to make sure to try to
benchmark that to private sector levels
and just wanted to mention avoiding
pension obligation bonds because there
have been some cities and states that
have issued bonds for the pension system
trying to market it as kind of
refinancing of dead but what's happened
in a number of cases is you have to you
have to pay interest to those
bondholders and so if the pension fund
continues to underperform you end up
even worse off because you have to pay
that extra interest of the bondholders
now in a lot of cases that performs they
tended to focus more on the new
employees this is why I mentioned you
have to start looking at the future on
accrued benefits for current employees
but most of the the efforts to date have
been just for new hires now that's going
to get you a lot of results in the long
run but in the first couple years you're
not going to see a whole lot of savings
it's going to be the kind of savings
that build up over time and after 30
years or so once you've got a whole
generation through the system you see
significant reforms but not so much in
the first couple of years and so it's
really going to involve a number of
budget reforms to ticket States to to be
able to balance their budgets while they
have these rising pension costs and
these are a number of our reasons
general of budget reform recommendations
I guess so with that I think I'll go
ahead and stop and be happy to take any
questions for me or Anthony
Thank You Anthony we've got time for
questions so if you like please raise
your hand and make sure you ask a
question and then so we get to as many
people as possible try to keep both the
questions and the answers concise yes of
course my bad that the security based on
mortgages and credit card debt common
before
they created a support question poison
how get back you propose I don't think
the government should be at one hundred
percent agree there's at there's almost
no room whatsoever that we need for the
government we don't need Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac we get rid of them we don't
need dodd-frank has a number of
regulations one of them is called
qualified residential mortgages where
all of the regulators are basically have
gotten together and they've decided that
these terms define what's a safe
mortgage and if you want to securitize a
mortgage that doesn't make these
definitions then you have to meet
particular capital requirements you have
to maintain five percent of the value of
the risk of anything outside of what the
government says is a good mortgage and
this is could potentially run eighty to
eighty percent or so small banks at a
business that that do work with
mortgages because their balance sheets
can't handle it and it could concentrate
almost virtually all mortgages into the
top five to six banks and so anytime the
government tries to step in and said
this is what's a good mortgage you wind
up with those problems so we can get rid
of Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac we can
wind them down over five years the the
thing that I would say would be really
really beneficial towards actually
getting we can we can leave if we want
you know if the government wants to
leave FHA in place like I would prefer
there not be an FHA but if practically
speaking getting rid of the FHA is
impossible we can limit them to just
very very low income individuals so that
actually doesn't wind up the story in
the market very much but the one thing I
would say what we need is we need the
market to come together and put together
something like they have for accounting
standards there's a private group called
the financial accounting standards board
fasb and we can have a mortgage
underwriting standards board that's
market driven that kind of set standards
for itself so it's self regulates so and
the in essence sort of taking it and
taking the initiative by the market so
that the government doesn't come in and
try to do it itself thank you
you can write off your mortgage payments
ah against your taxes that I would
assume simply bids up the price of
housing for everybody to make that
straight line that you show just hire
are there any other bad things that
happen because of that and is there a
movement to get rid of it aside from
like Obama trying to raise more revenue
so that there is talk of getting rid of
the mortgage interest deduction the
Obama fiscal commission recommended
doing something with it actually reason
is publishing a study in two weeks that
deals with everything everything that
there could you could possibly imagine
with the mortgage interest deduction and
there's groups like the national
association realtor's that say if you
get rid of it it drives housing prices
are going to you know collapse by say
fifteen percent we actually don't think
that that's true we think that as the
mortgage interest deduction stands right
now it helps young wealthy individuals a
lot but for for most people it if we get
rid of the mortgage interest deduction
it won't decrease housing prices by more
than one two at most three percent and
even if it did that's a good thing what
the the big thing that getting rid of
the mortgage interest deduction that we
need to think about is if you just end
that deduction people's taxes will go up
and so the question so there is
definitely within the freemarker world
the idea that that that's more power to
the state and so what we should do is we
should decrease everybody's taxes so
that's revenue neutral now we could get
rid of it and that would help to cut
down the deficit we could get rid of it
take that extra revenue that's between
300 and 500 billion dollars to cut into
the deficit or we could lower
everybody's average tax rate by eight
percent and so for a lot of middle like
middle-income people they would see
their tax bills go down you could do you
know sort of either way it depends on
how you want to look at it from a public
policy perspective but getting rid of it
won't hurt the housing market it's it's
mostly at that point than a budget issue
keeping it though clearly drives more
assets towards housing and that's
problematic is
billion billion a year that's over it's
over that's over ten years so you think
think about it in the current deficit
yeah yeah the opposition to pensions is
coming from the left so the concern
there is that that pension spending is
crowding out social spending are you
seeing that elsewhere in the country and
if so do you think that there's a
possibility for coalition between
libertarians and the left on this issue
there really is because I think more and
more it's it's starting to be
acknowledged that this really is a
nonpartisan issue because pension
spending crowds out everything else now
whether your goal is to reduce the size
and scope of government and return those
hard-earned tax dollars to taxpayers is
we would argue or if you're a liberal
that wants more money to spend on
various social programs fact is the
greater the pension costs are the less
there is for everything else and so as
you say there is some opposition from
the left although they are very tied to
labour interests so there's another
factor there I you know I've been asked
well what the labour interests realize
that this the state or the city is going
to run out of money and so they'll be
you know kind of keep their demands in
check you might see that in private
sector because obviously the private
sector unions have an incentive to not
drive their company out of business and
lose jobs for all their employees in the
public sector you can't really go
bankrupt in the same sense as in the
private sector there's no real
bankruptcy proceeding especially at a
state level and so in California for
example the city vallejo went into a
missable bankruptcy and the main cause
was of course the pension costs were
just skyrocketing now even in the
bankruptcy proceedings however the city
was thinking well maybe we can get some
of these contracts avoided and reduced
to so we can get out of the out of this
problem well in the bay the way the
bankruptcy procedure proceedings work
the judge doesn't
make a util unilateral decision to say
well the city obviously can't afford
this so we're going to reduce the reduce
the pension costs so what ended up
happening was they couldn't reach an
agreement between the labor unions and
City and so they ended up not being able
to avoid those contracts at all and so
they've been going through this
bankruptcy proceeding and the pensions
are just as high as they used to be and
they ended up just having to decimate
services even in public safety and so
it's resulted in reduced quality of life
and taxpayers are paying just as much as
they were before yes in aust my
husband's family is Australian and we
talk a lot about real estate things they
do not get no really um in Australia you
don't get a mortgage deduction but you
get to keep capital gains or losses
against your income tax on any real
property which pushes the assumption of
risk on to the the homeowner and I was
wondering if you guys looked at that and
how that might affect housing and tax
policy and those kind of things by the
way they do have a bubble over there and
it hasn't it has not burst yet yeah
actually we just did a short memo
looking at the Australian housing market
and sort of what what we you know we're
not Australian housing experts but from
what would a little we've looked at it
seems like in the next two to five years
there could be a significant sort of
bursting at that particular bubble in
terms of how the capital gains exemption
look we we shouldn't have any taxes
against capital gains period and so that
in that ended up itself this wouldn't be
a problem if we had no capital gains
however or if we had no capital gains
taxes however given that we do singling
out housing in the
that does wind up distorting the way
that you use your assets versus put any
particular other investment and so that
that does create some distortion our
research show though it's not like
incredibly significant which is why
there hasn't been a lot of talk about it
it's usually is even in my talk it's
sort of thrown in there I sort of an
afterthought in it the mortgage interest
deduction actually I misspoke Nick in
2008 the the mortgage introduction was a
four hundred and seventy billion tax
expenditure just in that one year so
getting rid of it in the future you're
talking between 300 and 500 billion per
year that's really significant the
capital gains exemption is much smaller
than that significantly smaller than
that I don't know the exact amount but
it was small enough first not to spend a
lot of time looking at it yes
about ninety five percent of all loans
out there right now question is how do
you do a vest that many that much from
that corporate and who do to divest it
to you well specifically they have
between nineteen ninety percent of all
new loans that are coming out so it's
not all mike nine ninety-five percent of
all loans within the United States right
now that would be a massive headache
done wine but it is still significant
problem that there between ninety
ninety-five percent of any mortgage that
is issued today how you get rid of them
you can't do it overnight so we have to
be practical in that sense even if we
don't like to use the word practical we
have to say this is going to happen this
is going to have to happen over a three
to five year period and what you do is
you essentially take them in packages
and you sell them to the private sector
and this can be if this is done over a
five-year period of time there's going
to be a less of an impact on the actual
prices of those that the government gets
we we want to be careful on how quickly
we sell them because if we dump them all
out into the market at the same time
taxpayer is going to take a big loss so
we need to be careful about that so the
big thing though is that the private
sector isn't going to want to buy every
single one of those a lot of them are
toxic and so at the end of the day it
may be that the only thing to do is you
sell as much as you can and then the
rest of it will get run off in sort of a
bad bank of sorts the private sector
simply isn't going to want them
taxpayers have got them there's little
we can do about them and the losses
we'll just have to eat the losses on
those at this point we've suffered about
two hundred billion dollars in losses
fannie mae and freddie million freddie
mac's activities and the various
estimates on fiat like beyond that in
theory it could be up to another five
trillion but it's probably going to be
another 100 to 200 billion and we may
just have to eat it and just suck it up
and try and move on we
one more quick question let's make about
pensions is there a question of pensions
out there yes there was a step that
federal employee salary
the private sector salaries and it was
about 120,000 to 60,000 I mean who are
you I mean who are the people that are
in that statistic I mean as far as I
mean I Goldman Sachs CEOs are not in
there that are making six hundred
thousand dollars a year I mean is that
you know who are they using for that
target range alright the question was
about the the comparisons between the
public and private sector compensation
and just a minor correction that that
stat included both the wages and the
benefits but that includes it's an
aggregate for the entire private sector
and the entire segment of federal
government workers and so it's really
it's not quite an apples-to-apples
comparison right in the way that the
other the other USA Today study that
showed was thinking like a public sector
account or a federal pen that a promise
I program that's correct although if you
look back over last 10 years 20 years 30
years it's been kind of a growing trend
where the government salaries and
benefits have been increasing much
faster than the private sector salaries
in fact in the the last decade even
after you adjust for inflation federal
government employee salaries have gone
up about thirty-seven percent in the
private sector they've only gone up
about nine percent well I want to thank
Anthony Randazzo and adamsummers of
Reason Foundation for talking about the
absolutely horrible situation I think
the Sun is still shining taken four
grand we are going to take a break and
then are we back in this room for the
next reason day yes yes yes but I thank
you very Jen you have all the answers
thank you very much we'll see